[Music]  hey everyone's fine but over the weekend  a fire in the town of Calabasas damaged  some homes including the property of one  of the members of our show as  firefighters put out hotspots in the  hills neighbors watched thankfully  incredible those guys Wow  they saved the house it they saved the  neighborhood and rich Rosenberg knows it  got so close the shed at the edge of his  backyard caught fire  no this this is our own lebombo lebombo  is this true your shed caught fire yeah  it caught fire and but but you they put  it out before it all burned down yeah oh  okay well now I can see why they put you  on the news you were more cooperative  with those guys hey is that your pool  you're standing in front of yeah how  much like paying you you're one of six  guys that blows through a plumbing  fixture you got a pool that quick yeah  cool that's insane yeah that's a nicer  pool than I've got  [Music]  you